espérée nombre de députés pour faire
valoir avec coeur et conviction vos
idées vos valeurs et vos intérêts comme
pour défendre votre pouvoir d'achat ou
votre sécurité
dans notre pays en proie au doute et où
tout semble hors contrôle on voit que le
stade de france l'inflation ou la hausse
du carburant il faut des députés solide
et déterminé pour faire valoir la voix
des honnêtes gens celle des
entrepreneurs et des salariés des
familles et des retraités
celle de patriotes français qui
souffrent de voir leur pays dans cet
état dimanche prochain il est important
de ne pas laisser emmanuel macron
disposer d'une majorité absolue dont il
abusera pour appliquer ces méthodes
autocentré est brutal et nous imposer
son projet antisocial faire ce qu'il
veut comme il veut à votre place mais
sans vous et souvent contre vous si vous
laissez faire nous risquons d'entrer
pour cinq ans dans un tunnel un tunnel
sans lumière pour une majorité de
français cette situation sera peu
respirable avec des dizaines d'élus
rassemblement national vous aurez au
contraire la certitude d'être
représentées par des députés proches de
vous une opposition ferme mais
respectueuse de nos institutions et qui
porte avec courage un projet de
redressement pour le pays et pour le
peuple dans les circonscriptions qui
voit au second tour un duel entre la
république en marche et la nuque baisse
j'habite les électeurs à ne pas choisir
entre les destructeurs d'en haut et les
destructeurs d'en bas
à ne pas choisir entre ceux qui veulent
vous priver de vos droits et ce qu'ils
veulent nous priver de vos biens la
france n'est ni une salle de marché nine
zad dans le cas où un candidat autre que
le rassemblement national ferait face à
un candidat lrm ou nubes j'invite les
électeurs à agir en conscience en
fonction du sens patriotique de ce
candidat
électeurs du rassemblement national
électeurs patriotes de droite de gauche
et d'ailleurs et il est conscient ce que
la séquence électorale n'est pas fini
vous avez un rôle essentiel à jouer vous
pouvez faire entrer à l'assemblée groupe
national très importants comme jamais
dans l'histoire politique de notre pays
ce sera là une immense victoire pour le
corps national pour le peuple et pour la
france cette victoire du corps national
est à portée de main et de vote je
compte sur vous vive la république vive
la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]